India es el país que más películas produce
en todo el mundo.
Todos habéis oído hablar de la industria
de Bollywood ¿Verdad?
Pero os hago una pregunta ¿Cuál es el segundo
productor de cine?
¿Cuál iría en la lista después de Bollywood?
La respuesta es NIGERIA.
Seguro que ninguno lo habéis adivinado.
Pero, mis queridos amigos de VisualPolitik…
Nollywood produce muchos más títulos al
año que Hollywood.
Y casi nadie lo sabe porque, seamos honestos,
África es el continente olvidado.
La política y la economía africana a duras
penas salen en los medios.
Y por eso, podemos decir que los africanos
están viviendo un milagro silencioso.
Atentos a la gráfica.
Esta línea representa la media del PIB per
cápita de todos los países del África sub
sahariana.
Durante los últimos 40 años del siglo XX,
esta región apenas crecía.
Pero de repente ¡Boom!
En el año 2002 empieza a subir como la espuma.
En poco más de 15 años, los africanos han
triplicado sus ingresos.
Algunos países como Etiopía están creciendo
a ritmos del 10% interanual.
Y ya sé lo que estaréis pensando muchos:
a ver Fonseca, que la gráfica está muy bien
pero… ¿Realmente está mejorando la vida
de los africanos?
¡Vamos a ver!
Que nadie se espere ver rascacielos, ni centros
comerciales en cada esquina, ni una clase
media pujante.
Todavía no estamos ahí.
Es más, quedan regiones y países enteros
que no han mejorado.
Por ejemplo, la República Democrática del
Congo o la República Centroafricana siguen
hundidos en la pobreza extrema.
Pero hay muchas otras partes que están mejorando.
Por ejemplo, en Addis Abeba, capital de Etiopía
están empezando a abrir supermercados.
Esto, que os puede parecer la cosa más normal
del mundo es un paso de gigante si tenemos
en cuenta que hace 30 años todo el país
estaba subido en la hambruna ¡Pero no solo
eso!
Ya empezamos a ver empresas africanas que
se expanden internacionalmente.
Ahí tenemos el ejemplo de M-PESA, que es
un método de pago, o Ethiopian Airlines.
Y os preguntaréis ¿Por qué África está
creciendo?
¿Qué ha cambiado en el continente?
La respuesta es muy sencilla: paz.
Veréis, el primer requisito para que un país
se desarrolle es que no tenga guerras.
Después viene todo lo demás.
Pero ninguna sociedad puede desarrollarse
si viven en un campo de batalla continuo.
Y esa ha sido la situación de África durante
décadas: guerras de independencia, conflictos
tribales e, incluso, genocidios.
Sin embargo, hoy en día, la mayor parte de
estos conflictos han terminado.
Para que os hagáis una idea, en 1990, una
media de 45 africanos por cada 100.000 morían
por razones bélicas.
Hoy, esa fibra ha caído a 8 por cada 100.000.
Y todo esto ha ayudado a impulsar el comercio
y la inversión extranjera… sobretodo por
parte de China.
Sin embargo, como decíamos antes, todavía
queda muchísimo trabajo por hacer.
África no es ni de lejos una región próspera.
Queda el siguiente paso para desarrollarse
¿Y cuál es ese paso?
¡Exacto!
Tener industria.
Por el momento, África sigue siendo un continente
rural.
Salvo honrosas excepciones, todo lo que nos
llega de esta zona del mundo son materias
primas.
Y así es difícil prosperar.
Pues bien, es en este contexto en el que ha
ocurrido esto.
El mayor acuerdo de libre comercio en casi
un cuarto de siglo busca hacer de África
un mercado único
Habéis oído bien.
El objetivo es crear una versión africana
de lo que en su día fue el Mercado Único
Europeo, el germen de lo que hoy es la Unión
Europea.
Pues bien, desde el 30 de mayo esta área
de libre comercio es una realidad.
Hablamos de nada menos que 52 países.
Tan solo Benín, Eritrea y Nigeria no han
entrado a formar parte del llamado CFTA.
Vale, tenemos que hacer una actualización.
Tan sólo unos días de que termináramos
de grabar este vídeo, Benin y Nigeria firmaron
el tratado.
Pero la pregunta es… ¿De verdad este acuerdo
puede cambiar las cosas… o sólo son palabras
bonitas?
¿De verdad un acuerdo de libre comercio puede
mejorar la vida de los africanos?
Hoy vamos a responder a estas preguntas, pero
antes, vamos a ver un poco de historia.
SIN MERCADO NO HAY INDUSTRIA
Cuando hablamos de África tenemos que recordar
una cosa: África tiene 55 países, 1.300
millones de personas.
Es imposible hablar de África como si fuera
un único país.
Pero aún así hay algo que casi todos los
países africanos han tenido en común.
Casi todos fueron colonias de países europeos.
A duras penas llevan 50 años siendo naciones
independientes.
Pero… seamos honestos, todavía mantienen
unos lazos con sus antiguos metrópolis que
hacen que esa independencia sea más una ilusión
que otra cosa.
Normalmente, el principal socio comercial
de un país son sus vecinos.
Los españoles comerciamos con los franceses,
los franceses con los alemanes, los alemanes
con los holandeses.
Estados Unidos con México… Pero, ¿con
quién comercian los países africanos?
Pues la verdad es que comercian con cualquiera
menos con quien tienen al lado.
Por ejemplo: Costa de Marfil está al lado
de Ghana y de Liberia.
Sin embargo, a duras penas comercian con estos
países.
Su principal socio comercial es Países Bajos
y Francia, que ¡Oh sorpresa!
Es su antiguo colonizador.
No obstante, esta tendencia está empezando
a cambiar.
Si seguís VisualPolitik desde hace tiempo,
ya sabéis que la presencia china en África
se ha multiplicado de forma espectacular.
Y ¡Ojo!
Porque no son los únicos asiáticos.
Atentos a esta noticia.
La desaceleración de China abre las puertas
a la expansión del comercio africano con
India
¡Y no solo eso!
en los últimos 15 años el comercio de África
también se ha triplicado con países como
Turquía e Indonesia.
Es decir, que Asia ya supone un 45% del comercio
exterior de los países africanos.
Mientras tanto, el comercio con Europa representa
un 30%.
En otras palabras, que los africanos a duras
penas se relacionan entre ellos.
Y ya sé lo que estáis pensando… ¿Dónde
está el problema?
Cada uno comercia con quien quiere o con quien
puede ¿Verdad?
¿No se supone que hay globalización?
Pues sí y no.
Pensadlo bien ¿Qué es lo que envían principalmente
a Asia y Europa?
Pues que todo lo que estáis imaginando: materias
primas como el petróleo, el gas, oro, uranio…
en otras palabras, de todo menos productos
industriales.
Y todo esto tiene una explicación.
Por ejemplo, en el año 2017, unos ruandeses
crearon una empresa, la Rwanda Motorcycle
Company.
Esta empresa fabrica motos low cost.
Como os podéis imaginar, ninguna de estas
motos puede competir en calidad con una Suzuki
o una Honda.
Es decir, que alguien de un país europeo
o asiática no compraría jamás una moto
de Ruanda pudiendo comprar una de Japón de
Taiwán.
Así que, siguiendo con el ejemplo, ¿dónde
pueden vender motos los ruandeses?
Pues está claro, en otros países africanos.
De hecho, podrían venderse muy bien porque
apenas tendrían competidores.
No olvidéis una cosa: casi ninguna marca
internacional se molesta en vender en África.
Es decir, que si vivís en Congo y queréis
comprar una BMW, lo más probable es que ni
siquiera encontréis un concesionario donde
la vendan.
Esto significa que nuestros amigos de la Rwanda
Motorcycle Company tendrían un mercado entero
por explotar.
Todo esto explica que, aunque los africanos
comercian poco entre ellos, la mayor parte
del comercio interafricano no son materias
primas sino manufacturas.
En otras palabras, que si los africanos quieren
tener más fábricas, tienen que comerciar
más entre ellos.
¿El problema?
Que en África las cosas nunca son fáciles
y el comercio tampoco lo es.
Siempre ha tenido que hacer frente a varios
Las fronteras en África son sinónimo de
aranceles, burocracia y corrupción.
Si tu quieres enviar tu moto ruandesas hasta
el Congo, vas a tener que pagar aranceles
de hasta el 20%.
Pero además, tendrás que sobornar al guardia
de la frontera para que no tengas la mercancía
parada durante meses.
Como podéis imaginar, para cualquier empresa
es difícil ampliar mercados en estas condiciones.
Y más si tenemos en cuenta que, hasta hace
cuatro días, estos países se mataban entre
sí.
Y de nuevo, una fábrica de motos en Ruanda
no puede sobrevivir con un mercado tan pequeño
y tan pobre como el ruandés.
Necesitan ampliar el alcance de sus ventas
tanto como les sea posible.
Si no, es cuestión de tiempo que cierren.
Y lo mismo pasa con cualquier otra industria
que os podáis imaginar.
Si no puedes vender tus productos, ni siquiera
te vas a molestar en montar la empresa.
En otras palabras, que el proteccionismo está
haciendo imposible que África pueda salir
del todo de la pobreza.
Pero atentos, porque todo esto puede cambiar.
ENTRE MERCOSUR Y MERCADO COMÚN
“Diamante de Sangre” es una película
de Hollywood que nos cuenta, con toda la crudeza
posible, cómo podemos llegar a matarnos por
un pedrusco.
La conclusión de la historia es que a Occidente
solo le interesa de África sus materias primas.
Ante esta situación, muchos pensarían que
los africanos no saben hacer las cosas y hay
que ayudarles.
Pero esto es VisualPolitik y ya sabéis que
aquí pensamos de otra manera.
“La historia de África ha sido escrita
por otros; necesitamos ser dueños de nuestros
problemas y soluciones y escribir nuestra
historia”—Paul Kagame
Paul Kagame es el presidente de Ruanda.
En este vídeo ya os contábamos que es un
político con luces y sombras.
Su modelo a seguir es Singapur.
Así que, desde el punto de vista de la democracia
y los derechos humanos, Kagame deja mucho
que desear.
Ahora bien, en materia económica se ha convertido
en un auténtico modelo a seguir.
Pero, además de presidir Ruanda, Kagame también
preside la Unión Africana.
Esta organización nació en el año 2001
y está claramente inspirada en la Unión
Europea.
Su gran objetivo es convertir a África en
un mercado común al igual que Europa.
Y, por el momento, parece que lo está consiguiendo.
La zona de libre Mercado Africana entra en
vigor con la ratificación de Gambia
¡Exacto!
Hablamos del llamado CFTA.
El objetivo final es llegar a tener una moneda
única para todo el continente.
Algo así como el EURO pero en África.
Habrá que esperar todavía 15 o 20 años
pero esa es la meta que se ha marcado la Unión
Africana.
¡Ahora bien!
¡Esperad un momento porque no todo es tan
bonito!
Veréis, existen acuerdos de libre comercio
y… “acuerdos de libre comercio”
Por ejemplo, tenemos el caso del MERCOSUR.
Mercosur también nació para crear un área
de libre comercio en Latino América ¿Ha
funcionado?
Pues… no.
Los países que firmaron este tratado no estaban
dispuestos a ceder soberanía.
Ninguno estaba dispuesto a quitar aranceles
y permitir que sus empresas nacionales compitieran
con las extranjeras.
Es decir, que Mercosur tiene cientos de excepciones.
Sí, son palabras muy bonitas pero, a la hora
de la verdad, el comercio entre los países
que lo firmaron apenas ha crecido.
Y algo parecido parecido podría ocurrir con
esta supuesta área de libre comercio africana.
Por ejemplo: las dos principales economías
de África: Sudáfrica y Nigeria ven con muchísimo
recelo a este tratado.
Sudáfrica ha firmado a última hora pero
Nigeria se lo sigue pensando.
Y como os decía antes, Nigeria ha firmado
unos días después de que hiciéramos este
vídeo ¡Ahora bien!
No penséis que los nigerianos han recibido
este tratado con los brazos abiertos.
Todavía siguen muy recelosos de comerciar
con sus vecinos.
Y si no me creéis, mirad lo que decía su
presidente.
CFTA: No permitiré que Nigeria se convierta
en un vertedero — Muhammadu Buhari, presidente
de Nigeria
Básicamente, los gobiernos no quieren perder
el control de la poquita industria que tienen.
Tampoco quieren perder los ingresos que recaudan
por los aranceles.
Pensadlo bien, en un país como Nigeria, donde
apenas hay una economía bien estructurada,
es casi imposible recaudar impuestos.
Así que, casi todos los ingresos vienen de
lo único que realmente controlan: el comercio
exterior.
¡Pero hay más cosas!
Lo cierto es que este tratado, este CFTA,
genera tantas dudas como esperanzas.
Veréis, normalmente un tratado así se negocia
durante un montón de años.
Y el CFTA se ha logrado en apenas 4.
Han intentado abarcar tantísimas estados
de golpe que han dejado muchos asuntos fuera
de la mesa.
El documento final es una cosa muy genérica,
con buenas palabras pero pocos detalles.
Falta explicar cómo regular los temas de
competencia, de inversión y de derechos de
propiedad intelectual.
Y todavía no hay una lista de qué productos
se liberalizan y cuales se quieren proteger.
En principio, el compromiso es quitar aranceles
a un 90% de los productos en la próxima década.
Pero claro, si los Gobiernos optan por dejar
dentro del 10% con aranceles a las mercancías
que realmente importan, poco libre comercio
vamos a tener.
¡Pero esperad un momento porque hay más
problemas!
Efectivamente, el CFTA sería fantástico
para que África pueda crear sus propias fábricas.
Sí.
Pero, por el momento, África es un continente
agrícola ¿Y qué pasa con todos esos millones
de agricultores africanos?
Pues como os podéis imaginar, no están precisamente
contentos.
Los contrabandistas prosperan mientras Nigeria
trata de mantener alejado al arroz extranjero
En este caso, Nigeria tiene miedo de Benín,
que es su país vecino.
Benin se ha convertido en un gran importador
de arroz tailandés.
Por lo visto, el arroz tailandés tiene buena
calidad y buenos precios.
Si, de repente, Nigeria abriera sus fronteras,
sus productores de arroz lo podrían pasar
muy mal.
Y ahí es donde llega el gran dilema para
muchos gobiernos africanos.
¿Arriesgamos nuestro sector agrícola a cambio
de crear nuevas industrias en el futuro…
o nos quedamos como estamos?
Y así es como llegamos al tema central de
esta historia.
Según Naciones Unidas, si el CFTA se aplicara
tal y como quiere la Unión Africana, el comercio
interafricano crecería en un 52% para el
año 2022.
Es decir, tres años después del momento
en el que hacemos este vídeo.
Ahora bien, si los países miembros mantienen
sus recelos, podemos terminar con un tratado
fallido.
Es decir, que nuestros amigos de las motos
ruandesas seguirían sin poder abrir mercados.
Y si no hay mercado, no hay industria.
Así que ahora, la pregunta es para vosotros
¿Creéis que el CFTA conseguirá ser un tratado
al estilo Unión Europea o al estilo Mercosur?
¿Llegaremos a ver una industria africana
que saque al continente de la pobreza?
Podéis dejarme vuestra respuesta en los comentarios.
Mientras tanto, no olvidéis que sacamos vídeos
nuevos todas las semanas así que suscribíos
a VisualPolitik para no perderos ninguna de
nuestras actualizaciones.
Si os ha gustado este vídeo, dadle a LIKE
y nos vemos en el próximo.
Un abrazo y hasta pronto.